- Talk to us, how do you define success
for yourself, tell us a little about that.
- I have a really good
answer for this one.
This one I've known for a long time.
To me, the ultimate success
is doing what you wanna do everyday,
and having nobody have any impact on that.
(slow, tranquil music)
I wake up at six, I work out till seven.
I shower, spend 10, 15
minutes with my kids
before they go to school, and then
I go to my first meeting
at eight, or 8:30.
Usually breakfast somewhere
outside the office.
Usually I get to the office by nine.
And then from 9:00 a.m., so basically,
meetings from 8:00 a.m.
outside the office,
to nine, nine in the office,
til usually six or seven.
Every minute booked, no lunch,
no one minute to spare, no down time.
Meeting, after meeting,
after meeting, and you see
what's even happening with this, right?
- Been here for two hours.
- It's every second is booked.
Hi, how are you?
- [Woman] Good, how are you?
- It's a pleasure.
- [Woman] It's a pleasure to meet you.
- How are things?
- [Woman] Good, like great, now I'm here.
This is crazy.
- Where do you live?
- [Woman] L.A.
- L.A.
- Yeah.
It's crazy, I'm excited to just,
they said when something comes
up and something's right,
we can collab and we could do something.
- For sure.
- [Woman] It's just cool
to actually meet you,
and if something comes up
it's like, that's dope.
- 100%.
- Ready to go.
I'm like a mini-you in my segment.
- I love that, I believe that.
I've seen some stuff here and there.
I like where you're coming from.
- [Woman] 'Preciate it.
- I just really like positivity and good.
I'm all about it.
- [Woman] Right?
We need more in the world, and if we--
- Ready for this?
We have way more
positivity and light, it's just not loud.
- [Woman] Yeah, that's the thing.
- We don't need more of it in the world,
we need it to be louder.
That is the typical day, 30% of the time,
I'm traveling, going to clients.
Only 10% of my life is probably Gary V.
When I speak, or do appearances,
or do something like this, 90% of it
is me being the chief executive officer,
of VaynerX, which is the holding company
that owns the VaynerMedia and PureWow,
the women's publishing site,
and so that's how I navigate.
Just meeting, operating,
operating, operating,
meeting, meeting, meeting,
operating, operating.
How low can we go while
still being satisfied
is attractive to me.
For me, a purebred entrepreneur, she
or he loves the journey,
not the stuff.
One of the things I struggle with
in the current state of entrepreneurship
is a lot of people want
the
vacations, the watches,
even the (slurs words)
You guys have such an incredible imagery,
I think it's remarkable.
Who doesn't want fine things in life?
But I think that if you're in the game
just for the fine things
in life, for the bottles,
and the models, and the private planes,
I think you're gonna
lose, and it definitely
is not my definition of an entrepreneur.
My definition of an
entrepreneur is somebody
who can't live without doing their thing
and trying to create,
literally suffocated.
For me, I think that that's what's
amazing about anything, which is, there's
many different definitions.
For you,
go out, work your face off, win,
and reward yourself with
something is exactly right.
For me, the reward is pouring more
of the dollars and
energy into the company,
not buying stuff for myself.
It's one and the same.
I don't judge.
I talk a lot about like "Stop posting cash
"and Lamborghinis, and private jets,"
not because I don't think one deserves it
after they work hard, it's that
so many of the people on Instagram
that're posting that are fronting.
- 100%.
- They're literally driving
to a private plane pad,
taking the photo, and then driving home.
They're full of shit, and so, to me,
I think it's amazing if somebody wants
to buy an Armani suit, or a $5,000
belt, or a diamond ring
for a hundred thousand.
I don't, but that doesn't
mean that's right or wrong.
What I'm doing with that
same hundred thousand,
instead of a ring, is I'm
hiring two more people,
because I'm trying to
buy the jewelry company,
not a piece of the jewelry.